- 1, 2, 3... Et c'est parti!
- Malgré la pandémie,
Vincent Guzzo inaugure
à Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
un tout nouveau cinéma,
et avec son visage au plancher,
il compte bien b
de bonnes affaires.
VINCENT GUZZO,
propriétaire des cinémas GUZZO
- Il y a encore, je pense,
de l'argent à faire. C'est sûr
qu'il y en a moins qu'avant,
parce que les studios américains
en prennent de plus en plus,
mais dc'est à nous
d'innover.
- Innover... La chaîne Guzzo
mise beaucoup plus que sur
son maïs soufflé. Il y a ici
de nouveaux projecteurs au laser
et une offre bonifiée de jeux
pour faire concurrence
au visionnement en ligne.
aut offrir d'autres choses
que juste du cinéma pour que
l'expérience soit plus complète
pour que quelqu'un choisisse
de venir chez nous au lieu
de rester chez eux.
- Pour attirer les cinéphiles
en salles et les éloigner
de leur écran de télévision,
il n'y pas que les cinémas Guzzo
qui innovent. Ici, au Cineplex à
Brossard, on mise sur les salles
VIP, mais aussi, depuis cette
semaine, sur une toute nouvelle
salle baptisée
ScreenX. Il s'agit d'un écran
de 270 degrés.
(en anglais)
DANIEL SÉGUIN, VP principal,
exploitation, Cineplex Canada
- On pense qu'avec le ScreenX,
on va amener une autre façon
de pouvoir aller voir un film
sur grand écran. C'est que
le volmbre de films
qui est disponible en ScreenX
va être quand même très
important pour l'année 2022.
- Partout au Canada, les cinémas
bonifient leur offre.
L'Association des propriétaires
de cinémas du Québec salue
cette tendance.
ÉRIC BOUCHARD, co-prés., Ass.
propriétaires de cinémas, Québec
- Puis, à certains égards,
on a un certain retard
à rDéjà, on a vu
à Lachenaie, la semaine dern...
il y a deux semaines, une salle
qui a été construite, une toute
nouvelle salle ultramoderne.
Vous avez un exemple à Alma,
aussi, où il a mis des
projecteurs digitaux.
- J'ai rencontré votre nouvelle
double
- Avec le retour des films
à grand déploiement,
les cinéphiles retournent
ux au cinéma, mais il y a
une pente à remonter.
Vincent Guzzo est confiant que
les cinémas sont là pour rester.
- Je pensais que j'avais
tout vu. Aller au cinéma
va redevenir la sortie d'ados
par excellence, même si j'ai
toujours dit : T'as-tu vraiment.
ta première "date" avec ta
première blonde dans le sous-sol
chez ton père? Je ne sais pas!
- Si les choses semblent
reprendre leur cours normal,
dans les cinémas,
avec le variant Omicron,
les propriétaires de salles
espèrent qu'en 2022,
ils ne rejoueront pasdans ldans.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet